pas touche au système de sécurité
sociale dix mille manifestants rien que
dans la capitale et sur leurs banderoles
un appel général à sauvegarder l'état
providence le déclencheur un projet
gouvernemental de réforme des retraites
qui doit être voté avant la fin de la
semaine au parlement
tout va de mal en pis les retraites
seront un niveau inférieur et nous
serons pas en mesure de respecter nos
obligations
c'est la chose la plus importante en
décembre 2018 des centaines de grecs
s'étaient mobilisés en soutien au
mouvement français des gilets jaunes
beaucoup de syndicalistes mais aussi
toutes sortes de membres de la société
civile qui partagent le même combat
nous comptons sur notre pays pour
couvrir notre système de santé et
subvenir à nos besoins
quand nous serons vieux et tout cela
semble être mis en doute à présent
conséquences de la crise financière de
2008 la grèce applique une stricte
politique d'austérité comme en france
les grévistes les plus nombreux
appartiennent aux services publics mais
pas seulement
des journalistes ont observé un arrêt de
travail de trois heures en début
d'après-midi
[Musique]